i don't like this though kim kardashian
has been on a campaign to free the worst
people in the world from prison um or at
least to free them from the full
consequences of their crimes especially
if the consequence is the death penalty
because that is a
a consequence and at least still some
states in the union
and if you live in one of those states
you know that or you ought to know that
you know before you choose to commit a
brutal crime you
you know what you're getting yourself
into you know what the consequence is
you commit the crime and and uh now you
have to pay the price for it it's it's
really something that you chose
that's the thing about the death penalty
is that you the individual who chooses
to commit
if they didn't choose to commit the
crime i mean if they're if it's decided
this person is completely insane doesn't
have free will then we already
um it already is the policy that those
people are not going to be executed so
if they cho if they choose to commit it
they also chose the consequence they
chose the punishment because they knew
what it was going to be
kim kardashian doesn't like that though
and so this has been her this has been
her hobby horse for a while now
um and look she has not done anything
important or useful or good in her life
and she's decided to make this her thing
this is like her charitable endeavor
defending the worst scum on planet earth
but what we have to remember is that of
course this is all about her so here she
is
in an interview recently talking about
how the um the recent execution of a
criminal impacted her personally because
again it's all about her listen
i was working on the brandon bernard
case and he was in fact executed and
i remember crying and
feeling
so helpless because it was his last
phone call and he was telling me like
don't cry it's gonna be okay and
you know hearing that he was worried
that he would be claustrophobic in the
chair
and then
on his last call when he was in the
execution room said please tell kim i'm
not claustrophobic it's okay
and like moments like that i'm like if
only someone could see my day i'm like
hysterically crying calling every
governor that i could possibly imagine
to try to stop someone's execution and
then i have to run into you know a skims
fitting and i'm fitting and i'm crying
and i can't really get my work done
i was tough because she had to go to a
skins fitting the other guy was being
executed but she was crying at her skins
fitting
the level of narcissism required to make
somebody else's execution about you
is uh i mean it's off the charts
and now she's back at it so she tweeted
this way this is what she tweeted
i recently just read about the case of
melissa luccio and wanted to share her
story with you
so remember she just read about the case
just read about it and already she's
decided she's she has passed her own
verdict
she says she's been on death row for
over 14 years for her daughter's death
that was a tragic accident
jess found out about it
you know probably read the wikipedia
article or something and has already
decided that um melissa luccio who was
convicted of murdering her two-year-old
daughter actually was a tragic accident
kardashian goes on to say that lucia's
two-year-old daughter
died from falling down the steps
that's the that's the claim anyway um
actually it died two days after falling
down the steps allegedly but nobody ever
sought medical attention for her
but it was all it was all a terrible
misunderstanding on an accident
um kim kardashian actually deleted this
tweet sort of confusingly deleted it but
is still openly advocating for lucio and
defending her
hasn't really explained why she deleted
tweets
here are the facts though and kardashian
is not the only person coming to melissa
luccio's defense and saying that she's
uh you know she's really the victim here
and and it would be a terrible injustice
executor so here's here's what happened
i'll just break it down quick summary
um
her two-year-old child was um
founded
in in her home
two days after this supposed fall
now already this raises some questions
like your child fell down the steps
and was it turns out fatally wounded
and you never sought medical attention
for her
that raises some serious questions
then you get some answers to those
questions when you find out that there
was bruising all over her body
clumps of hair pulled out of her head
and bite marks on her body as well and a
broken arm
the physician at the hospital said it
was the worst case of abuse he'd ever
seen in his life
a pathologist
looked at the autopsy said the autopsy
showed that she died from abuse
she did not die from
you know a fall down the steps
also keep in mind that
she fell down the steps quote unquote is
that's like the classic
abuser
rationalization that's the excuse that i
don't know every abuser in history has
given
or at least 90 percent of them that fell
down the steps how often have we heard
that one
and
falling down the steps how does that
result in bite marks how does that
result in your your hair falling out
and once again even if somehow in some
unbelievable
coincidence
the child happened to fall down the
steps in such a way as to cause all of
these injuries i don't know how that
could even
possibly be the case
but then then she would have been very
visibly
and grievously injured so why didn't you
seek medical attention
there's no explanation for this and then
you find out that lucio actually
confessed under interrogation
that she's that
that she's responsible for the death of
her child
now yes now this this interrogation this
confession is being um used by lucio's
defenders to say that uh to
to say that the whole thing was was
invalid
because she confessed under it was like
five she was in she was being
interrogated for several hours like five
six hours
and she denied it
many times before she finally admitted
it
and so our defenders are saying well
there's five hours of interrogation and
then she confessed
well that's what an interrogation is
that's why you call it an interrogation
what
how do you think an interrogation is
supposed to work are the cops supposed
to just like
you've got a dead child here
with all of these wounds on her on her
body
and you bring in the mother and you sit
her down and you say
did you kill your child and she says no
and then you just say oh okay well never
mind then
no obviously they had especially when
the when the when the
the physician at the hospital tells you
that this is the worst case of physical
abuse of a child he's ever seen in his
life
and then given all the other
circumstances that's going to make you
as as a police officer
as an investigator very very suspicious
about this woman
and so of course you're going to
interrogate her for five hours
interrogate her for 15 hours
until you get an explanation that makes
sense
i don't even understand this whole thing
about
this is so common that we we hear uh as
well the person only confessed after x
number of hours of interrogation that's
the point of the interrogation
are you suggesting that the cops should
just take the first answer they get
she killed her child and she
obviously she didn't want to admit to it
right away she would prefer not to admit
to it
she doesn't want to go and be in jail
for the rest of her life or get executed
so part of the interrogation is breaking
through those initial psychological
defenses to try to get to the truth
that's what it's that's the point
uh so to me this is very this is very
clear cut but kim kardashian
you know spent spent five six seconds
reading about the issue and decided that
uh melissa luccio is
is really the victim here
a woman convicted of
brutally
beating her two-year-old to death
is the person we're supposed to feel
sorry for
sorry that's just i i don't i don't have
that in me and it's not because i'm
callous
i think the callousness is all on the
other side
you know you this is this is misdirected
sympathy
this is this kind of twisted form of
compassion that you get from the left
you get from people like kim kardashian
and it's it's um
among other things it's an easy kind of
compassion because she doesn't feel like
if you're a morally decent person you
should feel this intense
unbridled
revulsion and anger
at um this kind of violence against a
child
i mean you should have a rage boiling
inside you at the idea that a child was
beaten to death
and and that's what that's what a
morally healthy person experiences
that's the hatred we talked about
a couple days ago if you're a loving and
compassionate person you should have
hatred in your heart for
things like this
the brutal victimization of a child you
should hate that you should hate that
with every fiber of your being
now by all appearances kim kardashian
doesn't have that inner she just doesn't
she doesn't really feel much about the
fact that about the victims and the
terrible things that were done to them
and so it's easy for her to have quote
compassion for the
for the criminals
because she doesn't feel any anger about
what they did
she doesn't feel any righteous justified
anger that's where the compassion comes
from it's it really comes it you know
what it comes from it comes from
indifference
it's not compassion it's indifference
and we tend to confuse those two things
a lot in this culture
there are a whole lot of people who are
very indifferent to injustice and they
get away with
positioning that indifference as
compassion
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated